hi there Steve coffin here and I'm gonna
talk about languages again and I'm gonna
talk about words vocabulary words
because in my Greek which I started I
think around March April and did for a
few months and then I left it because I
went to Ukraine and did some Hebrew so
I've been at it for three or four months
and my statistics at linked tell me that
now I know 4,200 words or something when
I had three thousand words I decided I
would start speaking so I'm speaking
three or four times a week with a tutor
before that level I didn't feel I had
enough words and I've had enough
exposure to carry on a conversation
remember that I learned my words through
listening and reading
I don't we learn my words from lists of
words and so now that I'm over 4,000 I
have finally decided to start tackling
interesting content and interesting
content at the sort of at this level is
newspaper articles newspaper articles
are great because they're relatively
short they're normally not written at a
very high level in terms of the kind of
vocabulary they use in English we have
seen them described as being anywhere
between sort of grade seven reading
level and grade eight reading level it's
not very difficult material it's not
like literature and very often I mean
you select the articles that you want to
read and so they can be on subjects that
you're familiar with and obviously if
you're familiar with the subject you're
gonna have an easier time understanding
it that's been demonstrated familiarity
with the subject is a big boost to
comprehension and you can stay uncertain
you know stay on economics and you'll
get a repetition of economics terms you
can save phrases there which I do at
link of course but fundamentally it's
these vocabulary words though it's the
words you know that sort of is that
these are the milestones of how you're
doing
because and I think this is another
important point language learning it's
not about someone
explaining the grammar to me because
ultimately I'm going to need a lot of
words so these words that are the
milestones
I've often called it the mechanical
rabbit that the you know the greyhound
racing dog chases after they lead you to
a discovery of the language initially
you're dealing with left less
interesting content but you're motivated
to get a grip on the language but now
I'm at that stage where I'm I'm reading
about Greece about different economic
and political issues in Greece and my
vocabulary is increasing and I'm
discovering more about the language and
we we discover the language ourselves
because to try to present all the
details of the grammar and then test you
on the grammar it's it's just too much
up front as I discover the language and
I in my mind have form certain questions
about certain endings in Greek or about
certain tenses in Greek and there are
there's so much in the way of resources
on grammar I just look it up
I can google it I can buy a Greek
grammar book if I want there's no
shortage of resources that you can go to
to satisfy your curiosity about grammar
once you have seen certain things in the
language and what answers to certain
questions and so as you progress in
discovering the language you can ask
yourself different questions but the the
measure of your progress through the
language is this number than your
vocabulary the number of words that you
know so if I look at my statistics at
link and this is why we have statistical
add link I know this four hundred four
thousand two hundred words I have saved
close to sixteen thousand links those
are words and phrases that I have saved
so those are now no longer completely
new to me but they're not yet learned
and as I review them in link you know if
I'm reading a new text anything that I
have previously looked up is gonna be
there in yellow for me if I feel I know
a little better I might advance it in
status I like doing that because
it makes that shade of yellow a little
lighter I like seeing lighter colors on
my screen it gives me a sense of
achievement and eventually I move those
to known so potentially I have 16,000
it's not all words many of them are
phrases about presumably about at least
10,000 of them are words these are words
that I'm in the process of getting to
know and as I see them again and again
in different contexts they gradually get
converted to known so that my when I
started speaking I knew 3,000 words that
wasn't very long ago I'm now over 4,000
and now that I'm into reading
interesting content I expect that number
to go to 5,000 6,000 right now if I
bring in a newspaper article as I just
did I went to toll vemma which is a
popular newspaper in Greece Tovey MoDOT
gr I saved three or four articles I can
do it on my iPad I can do it on my
computer bring it into link and I can
see the on average these articles that I
bring in have about thirty thirty five
percent new words for me these are words
that I have not yet come across at link
now that includes proper names so those
proper names I IX them out so they don't
count in my statistics so probably a
certain percentage of those are actually
names so the number of unknown words is
is gonna be around a third at this point
and I from my own experience as I learn
more vocabulary items again more words
that percentage is gradually gonna go
down from 33 percent to 25 percent to 20
percent 15 percent and when I'm at 15
percent that's a real sweet spot where
I'm really able to get the hang of
things as I read but even now I'm
certainly gaining meaning from these
articles of course I have to look up my
yellow words again I have to look up all
the new blue words about 1/3 of the
words but it's it's meaningful I know
enough I have enough of a sense of the
structure
I am gradually discovering more and more
of the language so let
words be your milestones let words be
what drives you to discover the language
and them as required you look up grammar
points or you hook up with a native
speaker and start using the language so
there you have it just touching again on
the importance of vocabulary words and
and counting words as a measure of your
progress
bye for now
[Music]